[Music]
so today i uh must address a certain
pr crisis that i've been embroiled in
all week and have tried my best to
ignore but it's obvious that i'm not
going to be able to remain silent about
this
many of you especially those who watch
this show on youtube know that i often
will post music reviews to my channel
we've
reviewed all kinds of different songs by
different artists from different genres
some of the songs are artistic
masterpieces like
we paid by little baby cuda by
takashi69 great song some were a bit
subpar like driver's license by uh
ariana grande or whoever it was
and then there was the other song by
that chick from tiktok the point is
we have reviewed the whole gamuts but
until this past weekend we had not
reviewed any k-pop music
and that was an oversight that we knew
we had to remedy k-pop for those who
aren't familiar
is short for kill me now pop because it
causes those who are subjected to it to
experience suicidal urges
and i know what you're thinking oh
that's just regular pop music that's all
pop music and you're right
it's very similar to pop music most pop
music except this is asian in origin
um the biggest group in that genre is
called bts and they're the ones i
reviewed on my channel
as i explained in that review the first
few times i heard the name bts i
confused it with btk
the buying torture kill serial killer
and i was rather disturbed frankly to
see that so many adolescent girls were
such big fans of his work
and then i found out that bts and btk
are two different things and and i was
relieved
but then i listened to the song and i
realized that in fact i might actually
prefer btk
over bts in hindsight the point is that
i
i didn't especially like the song it's
no
we paid that's for certain and so i gave
bts two thumbs up for for not being
serial killers as i previously suspected
but i did ultimately give them two
thumbs down for the song itself
which was terrible as it turns out
bts fans do not like it when you don't
like their music
even though my review was honest and
respectful
well honest anyway still the bts fans
have
flooded the comments my messages my
inbox with it with a deluge of extremely
aggressive criticism
as it stands right now my video has
about 10 000 thumbs down and 10 000
comments almost all of them negative
and the comments generally fall
somewhere on the scale between i
disagree with your opinion about bts
and and uh i'm gonna find you and kill
you for not liking my favorite boy band
generally leaning more towards the
latter end of that spectrum
uh and also i i've been informed
especially through many messages on
twitter that um
i am ugly uh stupid white
male one message stipulated that i am
both ugly and hideous
to two different things i guess so i got
all my bases covered
another adds that uh i'm an ugly jealous
and my face looks like
many comments took exception to the fact
that i allegedly accused
all bts fans of being deaf and i've been
informed that this is bigotry
and uh and miserable and i'm and you
know i'm a miserable
hateful sack of garbage especially for
making a comment like that
during what is apparently disability
awareness month
many other comments insisted that i need
to do my research before
talking about bts again and on and on
and on in summary people really didn't
like the video
really really really didn't like it
now this is the daily cancellation so
you're probably expecting that i'm gonna
now cancel
all of these salty pop fans for getting
so mad about my music review
but i would not dream of adding to the
trauma that i've already caused them
in fact today for the first time
i'm gonna cancel myself and also for the
first time i am going to say
sincerely and i really mean this i i'm
sorry i apologize
bts fans i am sorry truly
i'm i'm afraid i've been misunderstood
yeah i accused you of being deaf
i didn't mean it as an insult i just
assumed that you must be deaf
if you can listen to that music without
dry heaving
that's it i you know it's it's like when
you see a woman with a beer gut and you
say congratulations on the pregnancy and
she says i'm not pregnant
you you were going on context clues and
you arrived at the wrong conclusion
i was incorrect in my assumptions and
i'm sorry i'm also sorry for being ugly
hideous white and male if i could do it
over again i would have identified as a
beautiful woman before
recording that video that's what i
should have done that was my own
oversight
i take ownership of that and i apologize
for not doing my research
um i spent six months
reading through volumes of information
in literature before reviewing takashi
69
for example i traveled across the globe
i consulted experts i sought guidance
and insight
i climbed to the top of a mountain i
meditated alongside a tibetan monk
i prayed and fasted all to prepare me
for that youtube video
but for the bts video i admit i did none
of that
no research no consultation no prayer in
fact
i'll even admit we decided to do that
video at the last minute
because we couldn't think of any other
content and
i put literally no preparation into it
whatsoever
and disaster followed this is my fault
and mine alone but also mainly the
producers they should have stopped me
so blame them uh and i will live with
the regret for the rest of my days
i haven't slept all week i'm i'm
tormented by the terrified screams of
bts fans who discovered for the first
time that not everyone shares their
taste in music
their tears haunt me their anger their
disappointment
it stabs like a knife into my soul
much like the music stabbed like a knife
into my eardrums
what else can i do now but plead for
your forgiveness
i never meant to cause you pain i want
only for you to feel joy
and happiness in this world and in the
words of bts
from their song butter side step right
left to my beat
high like the moon rock with me baby
know that i got that heat
i don't know what that means but i'm
sure it applies here somehow
[Music]
and all i can say now is that today once
and for all
i am canceled
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated